monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues masqué
sion s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre nous assistons depuis deux
semaines au grand show médiatique du
président de la république le premier en
normandie le second en occitanie six à
sept heures de débats bien orchestrée
bien mises en scène
bref un président en campagne et
probablement plus en campagne qu'elle
écoute des problèmes fondamentaux des
français dans la ligne droite de cette
mise en scène nous apprenions hier que
la secrétaire d'état à l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes coanimera
l'émission ballos mon poste de cyril
hanouna pourrais je repense ses propos
ramener des gens vers le débat public
les français ne serait-il pas les
français ne serait-il pas assez subtil
ou assez intelligent pour avoir besoin
de ce type d'émission pour réfléchir
pour comprendre et proposer monsieur le
premier ministre
elles savent être accord que madame
schiappa participent à ce tokyo pour le
moins surprenant bon vous répondre la
parole autonome ciapa secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice je vous remercie
pour votre question tout en veillant
c'est tout en nuance je vais essayer de
vous répondre sur le même ton
pardon mon étonnement mais je trouve
assez surprenante l'espèce de mise en
abyme dans laquelle vous nous plonger
parce que vous déplorez que l'on parle à
cyril hanouna et vous même vous
consacrer votre temps de parole au sénat
a parlé de cyril hanouna
ça me semble assez surprenant vous
auriez pu parler de sujets dits sérieux
comme par exemple la semaine il aimait
fait dans la modération pour une fois 1
[Applaudissements]
madame la sénatrice il ya des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui regardent
toutes les semaines l'émission cyril
hanouna est ce que ces centaines de
milliers de personnes sont des citoyens
comme vous et moi
comme les gens qui écoutent france
culture comme les gens qui regardent
arte le grand débat national voulu par
le président de la république est
organisée par le gouvernement sous la
surveillance des garants sous l'autorité
du premier ministre pour l'organisation
ce débat est d'ailleurs très bien
organisé par mes collègues
emmanuelle wargon et sébastien lecornu
dont je veux l'a salué la mobilisation
exceptionnelle en un temps record et
bien ce grand débat national
il vise à parler à tous les citoyens il
n'y a pas de citoyen de seconde zone
madame la sénatrice le mépris de classe
le mépris de classe d'une intelligence
ya et d'une forme d'élites politiques
qui voudrait s'arroger la seule
responsabilité politique et la seule
capacité à accéder au débat politique et
au débat public c'est ce mépris de
classe qui a nourrit en partie le
mouvement des gilets jaunes chien qui en
veut non seulement gouvernement mais à
l'ensemble de la classe politique
je crois qu'on ne répond pas à des
problèmes politiques de 2019 avec des
solutions de 1999
ne vous en déplaise
alors madame la ministre est bien
entendu vos explications mais depuis
quelques temps chaque jour l'image des
hommes et des femmes politiques est
dévalorisé ne soyons donc pas surpris qu
avec ce type de mélange des genres les
français soient de plus en plus critique
à l'égard de leurs élus
vous participez ainsi à l'éloignement et
au rejet de la classe politique dans son
ensemble la politique vaut mieux que
cela
la politique ce n'est pas la télé
réalité l'exemplarité des élus
contribuer à leur respect notre rôle est
de tracer un chemin de créer l'envi et
deux de l'espoir avec passion à chaque
citoyen et en particulier aux jeunes
générations qui seront les adultes de
demain ramener le débat public à une
émission spectacle ne peut que
poursuivre le travail de dévalorisation
de la politique et ainsi vous y
contribuer mais peut être est ce voulu
alors comment aurions nous pu imaginer
un jour mais c'est vrai c'était un autre
temps
françoise giroud co animer une émission
avec guy lux soit avec les roses y trône
[Applaudissements]